For the UK, a country that once welcomed many immigrants,
including my grandfather,
to the country.
In fact, they begged them to come
and others to come to work in their factories,
to drive the buses,
due to labour shortages that were seen at that time.
And what successive UK governments have done,
Labour and conservative,
is that they have bit by bit
dismantled on immigration
and the deedar asylum processes. On.
On immigration,
the latest announcements mean that we are asking.
The UK government is asking migrants to come here
to look after our own family members,
but doing so by abandoning their own family members
back home. On asylum,
the UK government has virtually eliminated
any practical legal route
for those that are fleeing war and persecution.
So the policies of UK government
and disrespect,
they're not only morally repugnant,
but they're economically illiterate.
So the SNP, the Scottish Government,
uh, we of course,
value migration.
We value the importance of it to our social fabric,
but also to our economy.
To let me say unequivocally that in, in.
In Scotland,
the. The Scottish Government,
that the SNP,
we will always say that we are proud
of the benefits that migrants bring to this country.
And we are proud that they have chosen Scotland
to be there.